[Música]
boa noite
incrivelmente feliz em participar do meu
segundo tex meu nome à altura igreja
vocês devem estar se perguntando que
tipo de sobrenome é esse mas a 1 sobre a
portuguesa novamente peculiar então meu
nome é tudo da igreja é se você estiver
em dúvida como me chamar eu peço ajuda
para o bruce willis calma o estudante
então é apenas meu sobrenome eu não vim
fazer a bênção oficial do telex
eu tô aqui pra falar sobre essa relação
muito curiosa de tecnologia e os
relacionamentos humanos então acredito
que nós passamos por uma transformação
muito grande nos últimos anos e pouca
gente se deu conta disso porque eu falo
isso tecnologia tanto de comunicação
quanto de transporte sempre evoluiu
sempre esteve ao dispor de aproximar as
pessoas
então seja para conseguir conhecimento
com o jornal seja com tentará aproximar
as pessoas com as grandes navegações
as pessoas sempre estavam tentando se
conectar mais tecnologia estava a
serviço das relações humanas
quando nós tivemos o advento do rádio
isso ficou ainda mais facilitado quando
nós vemos as viagens aéreas com o santos
dumont quando nós vemos as viagens a
jato pessoas estavam cada vez mais
próximas em virtude da tecnologia
nós começamos a contar histórias com
novas tecnologias no começo em preto e
branco no começo elas eram mudas mas nós
estávamos contando aquilo que acontece
em outros cantos do mundo nós passamos a
ter cores nessas histórias nós passamos
a sair do preto e branco e pelo colorido
e dessas histórias coloridas nós
imaginávamos como poderíamos conversar
mais chegamos nos anos 80 e 90 com esses
aparelhos tão curiosos que nos
aproximaram e chegou o ponto entre 96 e
97 aqui no brasil que nós começamos a
desfrutar dessa tecnologia maravilhosa
de comunicação que foi internet
neste momento esse som é uma linha de
corte para a idade das pessoas é uma
linha de corte
quem conhece esse som se conectava o
sábado se conectava depois da meia-noite
e aqui nós passamos a nos comunicar de
uma forma radicalmente diferente mais
uma vez a aproximação e tudo muda em
final de junho de 2007 quando nós
passamos a conhecer o que é o smartphone
nesse momento um meio a dica aumente
diferente de comunicação o ser humano
passou a lidar com essa tecnologia nós
passamos a viver os sonhos mais loucos
dos jetsons que em 62 63 imaginava uma
forma de comunicação remota o que em
2010 se chamava ipad imaginavam uma
forma própria se comunicar em vídeo
através de relógios
o que hoje nós conhecemos como facetime
nos nossos relógios essa criação de
comunicação e proximidade gerou
verdadeiras fortunas num período de
tempo tão curto e fortunas e imagináveis
ao ponto que de 2007 a 2018 o que
acontece com empresas como apple e
amazon que saem de 17 74 bilhões de
dólares pressionado os gigantes de 2.1
trilhões de dólares o que são 2.1
trilhões de dólares pois é essas
empresas por revolucionar e aproximar
pessoas se tornaram maiores do que o
tamanho da economia brasileira é isso
que aconteceu nos últimos 11 ou 12 anos
e porque estou trazendo esse
questionamento porque eu acredito
seriamente que depois desse ponto do
smartphone do whatsapp do skype de tudo
isso nós passamos a viver um intenso
vício aquilo que nós chamávamos de vício
tem um grande amigo meu que teve cinco
sinais de que estava profundamente
viciado em nicotina é o primeiro sinal
foi o que ele ao acordar precisava fumar
segundo sinal a última coisa que ele
fazia antes de dormir era fumar
o terceiro sinal foi quando ele passa
acordar no meio da madrugada
precisando de um cigarro o quarto sinal
foi quando ele teve dificuldade de pegar
vôos com mais de uma hora de duração
justamente pela privação de cigarro e
por fim o dia que decidi largar o
cigarro foi quando ele se dá conta que
tomava banhos cada vez mais curtos
porque ele precisava fumar quando eu
mostro esse cenário de vício parece uma
coisa impensável mas nesses cinco sinais
a pergunta que fica é você já teve três
desses sinais para esse tipo de
dispositivo então quando você pensa
sobre isso qualquer a primeira coisa que
você faz quando você acorda qualquer a
última que você faz
ao dormir e se você acorda no meio da
madrugada você vai checar o instagram
ser whatsapp se você tiver no vôo e
começar a te pede para desligar os
celulares vai ficar inquieto e por fim
se o celular estiver em cima da bancada
no meio do banho você vai ficar pensando
ser uma mensagem muito importante ou se
é um meme que acabou de chegar
então o que nós chamávamos de vício está
na nossa mão da nossa vida ea partir daí
tem um ponto de inflexão e esse ponto de
inflexão começa a atingir as relações
nos últimos dez anos nós vivemos essa
transição de proximidade física para
distanciamento de conversa de diálogo e
distanciamento que eu quero dialogar
quero discutir com vocês esse
distanciamento mudou nosso comportamento
para sempre espero que não seja para
sempre mas nós somos verdadeiros zumbis
dessas telas
elas nos dominam nós vemos o mundo
através dessas telas e esse nosso
comportamento cria mudanças nas cidades
no nosso hábito de consumo em todos os
nossos relacionamentos ao passo que nós
vemos nos últimos dois anos cidades
pintando as suas calçadas dessa maneira
isso aqui é uma cidade que decidiu
organizar o fluxo de pessoas entre
pessoas que não usam o smartphone e
pessoas que usam o smartphone a parte
que mais me intriga dessa calçada é que
a última linha que está dizendo caminho
aqui por sua conta e risco porque é
perigoso andar desse lado onde os
distraídos não conseguem olhar o próximo
e nós começamos a ter comportamentos
inimagináveis a foto que eu vou mostrar
pra vocês de 2016 hillary clinton chega
no aeroporto encontrar os seus
apoiadores e ninguém quer conversar com
ela porque muito mais importante do que
dialogar com hillary clinton é ter uma
self dela
então eu costumo dizer que nos últimos
anos o vetor do turismo mudou nós
passamos a fazer turismo de ré
nós passamos a fazer turismo de costa
muito mais importante do que apreciar a
torre eiffel tem uma
foto de costas para ela então o
comportamento humano está sendo dirigido
pela mudança tecnológica e quando nós
olhamos isso o que aconteceu com o
marketing o que aconteceu com o comércio
que num primeiro momento nós conhecíamos
as lojas os produtos e indo até elas
pegando um carro no sábado e vendo a
fachada de uma loja é claro que o
marketing se digitalizou hoje é um
pleonasmo usar o termo marketing digital
se as pessoas são digitais a comunicação
com ela também passou a ser então a
partir da hora que você tem marketing
muito digital
o conhecimento dos produtos de forma
muito digital a preferência à compra e à
lealdade também digital
o engano que empresas e pessoas
cometeram foi compreender o seguinte que
o consumidor passou a ser conectado
através desse meio para a estatística de
um dos mercados compra de automóvel
as pessoas de 14 pontos seis vezes uma
concessionária para comprar um carro
hoje esse índice de 1.2 o erro de
empresas e pessoas só entender o
seguinte ora se eram quatro visitas e
agora só tem uma a tendência futura 0 eu
quero distanciamento do meu cliente eu
quero distanciamento das pessoas
a leitura correta exatamente antes disso
se eu tenho um contato com essa pessoa
ela esse contrato nunca foi tão valioso
nunca foi tão único ea tecnologia deixou
de estar a serviço da conexão das
pessoas é isso que nós temos que
resgatar e é isso que nós temos que
discutir o futuro nós estamos
construindo com tecnologia que avança de
forma exponencial e mentes que são
analógicas e agora são pilotados por
algoritmos então nesse contexto
tecnologia aproximar a realidade do
pensamento tudo aquilo que você pensava
em fazer e levava horas hoje está a um
clique essa ação está a um clique de
distância mas a reflexão é o seguinte
que tipo de pensamento que nós queremos
o futuro que a tecnologia estará ao
dispor para concretizar esse pensamento
e aí se a tecnologia é o tópico ou
distópica no filho é um ponto de
referência então da mesma maneira que
uma ilha por um náufrago quando ele vê
um barco ele fala ainda bem que está
chegando um barco para sair dessa ilha e
o náufrago cansado por semanas que ele
está tentando remarcando ele encontra
ilha e ele encontra descanso
tudo depende do ponto de vista e para
onde nós iremos guiar o uso futuro da
tecnologia então esse ponto de vista eu
quero tocar especialmente no ponto da
inteligência artificial é algo presente
na nossa vida toda uma discussão de que
dados nós estamos compartilhando quem
está tendo um conflito de interesse
comercializando esses dados e como é que
isso influencia o nosso julgamento as
nossas decisões
a nossa tomada de decisão democrática
por exemplo essa discussão da
inteligência social tem que ser muito
bem pontuada por que digo isso
a pergunta que surge de tempos em tempos
é quando robôs irão substituir pessoas
ora não funciona dessa maneira não vai
ter uma data não será 25 de maio de 2000
e alguma coisa a reflexão você tem que
fazer primeiro ponto você já é parte
robô fruto daquela colectividade porque
eu digo isso anos atrás
há 20 ou 30 anos atrás uma pessoa
lembraria seguramente de 15 a 20 o
número de telefone hoje você não lembra
de cinco desses números em caso de
emergência você não consegue ligar para
ninguém porque você não lembra porque
parte do seu cérebro da sua memória já
se tornou nuvem já se tornou o hardware
tá pedaço do seu smartphone pedaço na
nuvem de uma dessas empresas
se você tiver que buscar uma informação
antes nós memorizá vamos agora ela está
a um clique de distância então parte de
vocês já é roubo
a reflexão não é quando os robôs
chegaram que data vai ser essa do juízo
final dos robôs tomando os nossos
empregos a tecnologia através da
automação toma pedaços da nossa vida a
cada dia
só que nós estamos deixando esses
pedaços serem ocupados e nós temos que
pensar o que nós vamos fazer para ocupar
como que nós vamos pilotar a nossa vida
como é que nós vamos estabelecer
conexões e aí uma grande bobagem a
pensar que a automação vai substituir
empregos a tecnologia está substituindo
tarefas tarefas que você fazia de forma
analógica agora são feitas de forma
digital como é que vai ser isso no
futuro cada vez mais digital
só que aí está o perigo as pessoas estão
mais isoladas estão estão sentindo mais
solidão mais afastamento que nós temos
que resgatar voltar a colocar o ser
humano no centro e colocar a tecnologia
para trabalhar o nosso dispor
quando digo isso uma reflexão a
o jornal sobre quanto que o ser humano é
mais poderoso que a máquina
essa cena aconteceu em 96 maior jogador
de xadrez do mundo kasparov foi vencido
pela primeira vez pelo the blue da ibm e
nesse dia falaram agora não tem mais
volta os computadores vão tomar tudo
porque o maior gênio do xadrez foi
batido as máquinas vão ocupar todos os
espaços
vejam a limitação desse ponto de vista o
primeiro a máquina pode ter sido o
principal estrategista do xadrez nem
movimentar as peças ela consegue
ela precisava de ajuda de alguém aí você
pode até perguntar mas então o nosso fim
executar determinadas tarefas muito
operacionais que os algoritmos querem
fazer não é nem isso olhar correto sobre
a computação e inteligência artificial é
a seguinte se neste momento o caso prova
acaba de ser derrotado pelo algoritmo
mais poderoso da ibm se neste momento
esse prédio tivesse o soar de um alarme
de incêndio kasparov que o seu oponente
humano usariam uma outra esquina humana
da movimentação da mobilidade e da
agilidade e percebeu um cenário de
perigo e saíram calmamente do prédio o
computador continuaria calculando o
próximo lance de xadrez até derreter no
fogo então o computador
a computação é capaz de resolver peças
lacunas
nós somos complexos nós somos
incomparáveis
então é uma bobagem imaginar que vai
chegar o dia que a computação vai
conseguir substituir isso agora pra onde
que nós vamos
estou profundamente convicto que o que
nós temos que resgatar e focar uma
percepção que não este atividade
econômica não existe atividade no
planeta que não seja guiada por desejo
porções e por pessoas
então o que eu quero dizer com isso a
onde focar o focar tem que está em
valores que nós esquecemos nos últimos
anos quando parece que tudo tem que ser
resolvido por e mail tudo tem que ser
muito rápido tudo tem que ter um grupo
de ouattara pe
nós perdemos a noção da coisa que se
torna mais rara no mundo de hiper
digitalização que a capacidade de sentar
olhar no olho das pessoas conseguir
tomar café com elas conseguir
estabelecer conexões
porque eu estou mostrando isso porque na
era do auge da inteligência artificial
eu queria apresentar para vocês
o produto e ou serviço que foram
considerados alguns dos mais inovadores
no ano de 2018
eu queria contar uma pequena história da
gillette a gillette passou décadas
desenvolvendo tecnologia para melhorar o
seu produto ela fez uma lâmina duas três
quatro aquilo virou um cortador de grama
aquilo virou um objeto a cabeça movia
com o aparelho treme faz de tudo até que
em 2017 um grupo da gillette se deu
conta o seguinte que eles estavam
deixando de lado um grupo de 1.3 bilhões
de pessoas
ora mas que grupo é esse a gillette
sempre teve o melhor produto para as
pessoas que fazem a própria barba isso a
evolução tecnológica esse 1 bilhão de
pessoas um ponto 3 bilhões de pessoas
não fazem a barba por uma razão
ela só no final da vida delas ela sofreu
um avc
elas não têm um braço e quem faz a barba
delas é um cuidador e esse cuidador
sofre a cada dia porque ele precisa usar
essa lâmina de barbear com um pegador
que não foi feito pra ele ele tem que
usar o contrário
então nesse ano de 2017 a gillette
desenvolve coloca no mercado no ano
passado o primeiro barbeador em que o
cabo é ao contrário feito para
cuidadores um movimento de empatia de
olhar para o ser humano e colocar a
tecnologia ao serviço não há melhoria
incremental de uma tecnologia por
décadas
se eu te mostrar o comercial é
absolutamente chocante o que ele mostra
o seguinte um pai falando no final da
sua vida acontece uma reversão quem era
muito forte precisa de ajuda e eu venho
toda a manhã fazer a barba do meu pai é
uma honra porque ele fez isso por um
longo véu sobre a mata morre né
quero chevron shell e é esse aí não né
a medida foi [ __ ] sem conseguir lembrar
você quer
e aí nós chegamos um serviço mais
inovador 2018 é de um lado empresas
fazendo check out para ninguém falar com
ninguém tirando as pessoas das lojas de
outro lado uma rede britânica chamada
técnico resolveu fazer o contrário
investir no respeito ela se deu conta
que cada vez mais pessoas não iam até o
supermercado que se sentir envergonhados
por não ter capacidade de lidar com essa
tecnologia
nós começamos com o check-out muito
rápidos onde você pesa o produto nós
chegamos no modelo de loja que as
câmeras de techno que você pega e no
final essa empresa foi extremamente bem
sucedida porque ela falou o seguinte
existe uma camada da população que
precisa de ajuda uma camada que tem
demência uma camada tem esquecimento uma
camada que precisa de ajuda para ligar
para o filho porque ele esqueceu a senha
do cartão de crédito então ela cria uma
fila chamado slow em baseada no foco no
ser humano no respeito e usando o mínimo
de tecnologia para tornar a vida dessa
pessoa melhor
quando olha esse tipo de coisa eu me
lembro eu mostrei aqui o chapolim
no começo dos filmes e eu queria voltar
em 1940
parece que tudo é tão novo em 1940 no
discurso final do filme o grande ditador
chaplin diz o seguinte mais do que
máquinas precisamos de humanidade
mais do que inteligência precisamos de
amabilidade e gentileza em um mundo onde
as relações se desenvolvem através do
whatsapp e as pessoas querem se ver cada
vez menos a coisa mais poderosa que o
ser humano poderá fazer no futuro
são coisas como essa
[Música]
há um mês a obrigado